[Music]
a couple years ago i had uh hernia
surgery they basically take a patch and
sew up your intestines
so that your
stuff doesn't all pop out i don't know
you went to medical school
but the one thing they tell you
afterwards is don't obviously don't lift
anything don't strain yourself for the
first couple of days and the first day
back on my feet i had to go on a talk
show
and uh it was andy cohen's show watch
what happens live
as i was about to walk out and they were
calling my name
i see andy see me and i hadn't seen andy
and he's the host of the show and i'm
walking toward him and he gets this
really like wild excited look in his
eyes and he starts scampering toward me
and he leapt up on me
and i could feel for the first time
since the surgery like a strain and a
pull and ow and i like made a noise and
he was like what's wrong and i said
and then of course i had to launch into
the whole thing i said well andy i just
had hernia structure
so then we ended up talking about it on
the show we had to and it was
live at least your stuff didn't come out
that's true life could be a dream
life could be a dream
you're listening to life is short i'm
your host justin long and life could be
a dream sweetheart
[Music]
with me as always is my
hernia free i know you've never heard
i've had two hernias
ah you only had one oh snap
[ __ ] i feel so uh inadequate now yeah i
only had one i had two i had one as a
baby remember that's right one is a baby
that's true how a baby gets a hernia i
still never get the bottom of that
you're lifting heavy blocks uh um but
they told me they told our parents
unbeknownst to me that when a baby gets
a hernia
20 years later almost like to clockwork
20 years later
uh that
baby then an adult 20 that 20 year a
really big 20 year old baby
uh will get
uh another hernia on the opposite side
it's like nature's way of balance
bouncing out no and sure enough when i
was 20
i got another hernia did you know that
your second hernia was coming or like
might probably
it's it's very painful as you know her
yeah you feel it coming yeah i remember
when i got it i was
i was in a play
i was rough housing in a play we both
got hernias for you guys oh my god
what a lame way to get her it says so
much about it but also every man in our
family has had at least one hernia i
think we come from a long line
of hernia patients
hernia it tells you something about our
family tree they're like full of uh weak
pelvis
uh men
uh so why are you talking about uh
hernias today well because the hernia
surgery that we both had you've had two
one uh was performed by a doctor yes and
our
yeah uh our guest today played
a surgeon for nine years on tv
uh on a little show called scrubs
our guest is donald faison he's also a
dear friend of mine and
one of my favorites and i know that i
say that too often i i haven't i'm
starting to not believe you oh well no
but i do believe you yes
he is i mean he really is one of those
people that and it's happened a few
times in my life where within
minutes it happened with all of my close
friends within minutes you just know
that you're going to be friends with
somebody kismet yeah it's like that
scene and stepbrothers were like did we
just become best friends
uh you guys worked together two times i
mean i've known donald for years uh i
want to stay close to 20 years but um
we didn't work together until uh we did
a play together in san diego
at a great theater called the old globe
uh really loved doing that play uh it
was a steve martin play called picasso
with the le panagio and it's such a
wonderful experience but uh
and great cast and um
the best part though was was meeting and
getting to work with donald and then
again we did a movie called the wave
which we just premiered at a film
festival in austin which is where we are
now chris and i are in austin we're deep
in the heart of austin yeah what a great
city oh my god
uh you all know him from clueless of
course that was his breakout i'm keeping
it real keeping it real he talks about
that yeah he talks about that line and
uh the experience of doing that movie i
just rewatched that movie
and it is
i think my understanding of it when i
did the interview was a little bit
different it's
it's a lot more
grounded than i remember i mean the
dialogue and the acting it's not as i
remembered it being a little bit more
heightened for some reason but i i just
rewatched it on the plane uh coming to
austin who else was in the jeremy sisto
breckenmeier uh
it was strange to see stacy dash now you
know her as like she's like a big
conservative pundit um
but they were all these like fresh-faced
uh
actors
even while sean looks young
um and he's so it's and while shawn's
never really looked young dan
i know
dan hideau looked young um and paul ryde
it's crazy yeah uh he's also on a show
that just just recently premiered a
couple days ago called emergence
a
we'll talk about that we'll talk about
emergence and his uh family and
we're gonna get into all of it with the
infectiously charming donald faison life
could be a dream
do you leave the door open because don't
you yeah absolutely yeah you have to
leave the door open when you're pulling
around it's got to be one of the
weirdest things about having kids
well
do you remember your mom and dad leaving
the
door not really i remember one of the
first times i realized that women's poo
stinks
tell me we're recording this
but i'm sorry go on it was my mom's poo
and i was like wow that does not
smell good at all you remember that oh
absolutely i remember that and i
remembered like
this girl i had a crush on she was a lot
older than me like she was like in her
20s and i was like
eight or nine
and i was like we're boyfriend and
girlfriend and she's like yeah sure
whatever cutie
and she would babysit me
and she took a crap once that was so bad
i remember being like yo i don't like
her the way i liked her before
she smells like my mom exactly
wait did you so you obviously i was
going to say how did you meet her but
obviously no it was it was like she was
like uh my parents well no my parents
did a lot of touring when they were
younger through theater
and because of that they would meet
other companies and this was me hanging
out with another theater company and
this young lady was babysitting me from
that theater company and i remember she
was like i have to go to the bathroom
i'm going to take you with me and i
found it strange that i was in the
ladies room oh she took you in there
inside the thing and i had to sit and
wait
wait a minute where were you sitting
where like by the sink you know what i
mean and it was like there were stalls
and everything
and i remember being like this is weird
well your brother you have an older your
brother i have a younger brother oh
younger he's younger yeah yeah yeah oh
oh oh yeah that's not that's insulting
that i said in that song because i met
him right and he looks a lot older than
me that's true
a uh the time has not been good
you daddy i'm gonna keep it 100
would he laugh at that is he even gonna
listen yeah no he gets it all the time
he gets it all the time he's like
you know my little brother gets that
occasionally like who now who's younger
really just that is insulting
three years yeah same thing
yeah but they must just assume that he's
older absolutely he looks like he's way
older than i do
a little sherman and uh hemsley a little
bit uh do you think he does yeah i get
that more all right anything
i get that i look like george jefferson
oh yeah i remember this dude called me
george i was like 12 years old i was
young
he's like you look like [ __ ] george
jefferson and then threw a rock at me
a very archie bunker i think that
they're very very archery you look like
a little archie
oh i wish right it's also weird for you
because you're on this i'm like a stop
for you on this circuit of like yeah
it's very weird you're promoting yeah
i'm doing emergency it's very well i'm
promoting emergence and i'm promoting
the wave dude oh yeah very weird yeah so
we did a movie well chris and i will
talk about that but we
what's there to say about it we were we
shot it in albuquerque yeah which was a
lot of fun um we so don and i have
worked together twice in the last couple
of years albuquerque and san diego san
diego we tore up both of those cities
both cities we chose san diego
way more than we toured albuquerque yeah
we did a play uh picasso with the le
panagio yeah by and i both of us did it
was a steve martin play yeah and correct
me if i'm wrong but i think we both did
it for the same reason to work with each
other well yeah oh no oh that too and
then also because we thought steve
martin was going to be yeah so so we
both and we discovered this like a month
into maybe into the run we were like oh
he's never coming
so donald and i both got emails that
were like uh do you want to do we're
doing this play san diego huh and i
think we both had the same reaction
which is like yeah again correct me if
i'm wrong but like i'd like to do a play
right be really cool but ah san diego
it's kind of like no steve martin's
involved dude it's gonna be amazing and
he's gonna be involved he's gonna i
don't know if you've seen these he's got
plays on broadway now it's gonna be
amazing he's gonna he wants this to go
to broadway and he's gonna very handsome
so i said i thought oh my god this is a
no-brainer easy-peasy uh i should have
prefaced this by saying i'm so glad i
did it so much yeah absolutely great
experience really was but um
we both one night out we were like can i
confide something to you
the reason i wanted to do this
is so the punchline to this story is
that steve martin never throughout the
whole never showed up ever and then one
day
uh it was it was a matinee one of our
worst shows at that time
like easily one of the bottom three
shows and um
so how did you find out he was in the
audience i just figured i figured
something was up
the audience wasn't the audience that we
usually had at least it wasn't that one
show where the audience was just like
yeah yeah yeah next next right on their
phone one guy remember that one show we
had a guy who was on his phone yeah
oh it was just weird look we had one of
i thought we had one of the best jokes
ever like we set up the show you and i
and we always got applause for our
little joke where i jump out into the
audience and i grab the person's uh
their their uh program and i jump back
up on stage and i'm like you don't enter
yet you're on the wrong page or
something like yeah yeah yeah yeah right
something like something like that you
had to basically you had to go and grab
an audience members every night yeah
an audience members program old lady
once was like
this is in san diego in a kind of a
wealthy area of san diego beautiful
balboa beautiful bubble park um
oh i remember bubs was this sports bar
that we would go to
every freaking yeah night a lot and one
of those basketball hoops yeah no like a
whole basketball half court right well
it was in the hole it was like the size
of this booth yes
we're not in a very big booth right a
picture with the audience but it was
just like classic you know screens
everywhere and we
for whatever reason we kept going back
we loved that place
and i remember the bouncer so i'd be
always be like oh cool you're doing a
play you know like that's really awesome
that's awesome it's like real acting
right um
did you ever get the sense that like
i always chose like the smallest person
that's not necessarily good
[Laughter]
the person that wasn't going to be like
i'll choke
the most easily threatened person let me
threaten you let my let let it be from
me and not you on yeah exactly you know
what i mean exactly it was safer that
way you never had anyone record like oh
don't touch the the old lady one time
she was like no
i was like come on give it up
i remember one time i fell and i cut my
leg up trying to jump back up on stage
oh i don't remember that yeah i do i
don't remember any of the lines anymore
oh really yeah very few yeah we had that
one joke in the beginning where i
grabbed the thing and i come back up on
stage and it always got applause no
matter what and i remember that one time
there was only one time in the whole
thing
where we did the whole spiel
and nothing and it was like and i
remember you looking at me like here we
go
it's gonna be a long it's gonna be a
great
yeah we're gonna have to grind it out
because there's nothing worse than doing
some of these as good as we thought the
jokes were
if they fall flat it's like they're
choked they're clearly like bits so if
they don't if there's no reaction to
them it's just like
uh yeah here we go it's hard to keep
going it's hard to like okay um
let's try this joke for you guys maybe
he'll like that's why i don't think i
could ever be a stand-up comedian i
don't have that in me yeah i would like
to try but then when i i know right when
it's about to go down i'd be like i
don't want to do it i don't want to do
it
because you and you haven't done
stand-up though not really i've like
hosted things you
that was more like improv i went on
stage and like had audience members
throw balls like dodge balls at me
really yeah yeah it was like and i'd
improv stuff with vince
it was vince vaughn's comedy tour right
you never thought about doing that but
nah [ __ ] that no yeah no way and you
hadn't done a play in a while i hadn't
done a play since i was like 18 years
old wow and i was 39 wow no maybe no i
was 40 something it was a few years ago
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
you're good at remembering things like
that well i had to do my research right
uh i also remember when steve martin
came and afterwards we were like yeah i
mean yeah i'm meeting you excited to
meet him uh and it's it's one of those
things where like it had been built up
way too much he he he could have like
hung out with us and and just chit
chatted for hours and it still wouldn't
have been enough right i'm like wait a
minute right but it was he literally
only stayed for like 15 minutes yeah
yeah 15 minutes it was i love the show
it's great thank you guys yeah thank you
all
goodbye yeah i'm out i remember being
like [ __ ]
i know that's why i took the show me too
but at that point it was like i had
already been so happy that i did it so
it was like yeah but can you imagine if
that had been kind of a shitty
experience in life and he never he shows
up once and it's like what the [ __ ] have
you been right no dude no i couldn't
imagine thank goodness we had such a
good time i know thank goodness it would
have been a lot better if he would have
showed up
all the time but then i thought how
nerve-wracking would that have been you
know if he had been there because the
way it was sold to us as we said was
that he was going to be in in rehearsals
right right like make i imagine that he
was going to be kind of making some
changes to the script right like
so and now in retrospect like that
experience was so freeing and fun and
like i never felt like like barry
adelson that the director was amazing
such a nice guy and like just not at all
judgmental or right um it would have
been weird to have steve martin i was i
was really hoping that steve martin was
going to teach me his comedic stylings
and i was going to steal i was going
gonna steal everything that was my goal
i was like if he should when i see him
yeah everything that he has is going to
be mine yeah i just want to like a
hidden camera i want a camera following
him around just jack all of his [ __ ] but
then he never showed yeah yeah but i
still had a great time
such a great time um and then the movie
we did in albuquerque is the wave is
coming you can't come to austin i cannot
come to austin such a shock
it is a shame
but probably for the i mean my delivery
no doubt and you live in austin too
don't you i lived there yeah you moved
and i moved i got i i sold the place
yeah how long ago uh about a year
oh yeah what are you talking about you
didn't tell me none of this about a year
ago oh right on you know i was funny i'm
just going to bring some green crack oh
i'm glad you didn't
i'm so glad i've stopped smoking i
haven't smoked weed in so long
i stopped no kidding why because i was
living in jersey and i don't want to i'm
you know i don't i'm i'm taking this job
really sir oh oh yeah while you're
working and uh
like
i don't know man
your eyes are darting over to the abc
i'm just
like
i don't know how abc is going to take
this well it's good to hear that you're
you're not smoking weed anymore i do not
smoke weed i haven't smoked weed since
like may
wow yeah i'm
that's sort of heartbroken i'm
if you would have bought green crack i
would have looked at it and been like uh
damn well i'm glad i didn't but then i
thought like even if you had been
smoking weed what are we gonna
it'd be
it might be interesting
you can't go to jail in new york city
for smoking weed anymore oh right it's
no longer a criminal charge i didn't
mean that but maybe we go to like
podcasting jail for just having a like a
really weird episode we get real quiet
all of a sudden
it would just get real quiet long
stretches just looking
and then bursting into laughing right
for no reason you gotta say
i do remember that night dude yeah we
had a lot of fun at bubs i'm sorry you
guys couldn't have been there but we had
a lot of fun at bubs dude yeah i've
never met one look dude there's only
you're like the only person that i know
that no matter where we go somebody
wants to jump on you dude you're like
the only dude i know dude no matter
where we went in san diego somebody yeah
somebody would always be like what the
[ __ ] man i'd be like what are you doing
i didn't do anything he's harmless what
is he doing
i know i attract some stranger strange
aggro
yeah uh that's right and and i found a
picture recently of um i was from like i
was i didn't even remember i definitely
didn't remember taking it but it was
from
i think uh toronto like
vegas maybe years ago yeah i found what
you would uh lemon yeah that was vegas
yeah that was vegas all right so every
time i see you we have we have a great
time uh we have great times yeah
your your parents
it's amazing to me that you you grew up
around actors you grew up in the theater
world um and your mom is still an agent
she's an agent yeah tell the story about
how that happened so i was i got a job
at my agency because i wasn't working a
lot right so you started working when
you were how old uh professionally
junior high school where i was getting
jobs that were like uh on
television so i started
sixth grade i got my first commercial oh
my god yeah and then i didn't work at
all after that what was the first
commercial sorry don uh it was oatmeal
raisin crisp and i was like look what
they've done 2-0 meal and that was my
line and then i had like this i had like
four shirts on
i remember stealing all four shirts it
was like polo after polo polo and i had
never had a polo shirt before i checked
those things i left with them i still do
that do you oh yeah just wardrobe stuff
my whole all of this this is i mean this
maybe that's yours yeah
that's you i'm wearing a leotard
you knew that was mine um
yeah yeah i still didn't love it yeah so
then you didn't work so i didn't work
and my agent was like why don't you work
for us oh man uh we'll give you a job
and what you'll do is you'll
answer the phone and when we have
auditions come through
you're going to be the one that gets the
head shots and puts the resumes on the
head shots and you put them all in the
envelope and you send them to the
casting director
i was old enough to have a job okay okay
this was actually after
high school and everything like after i
was when you were 17 you did a national
big national commercial that i remember
i'm looking for yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah
16 when i did that so this is after that
this is a few years after that right i
had worked a lot
but not a lot like like i did enough to
pay for high school and you went to
professional children's right and so i
paid for
high school and
that was it and i didn't have i did like
a couple of like new york undercover or
whatever it was that was big
blue i never got on that one you never
got on college
that's all right it only hurts a little
i wish yeah i know are you [ __ ]
kidding have you seen the folgers
commercial in a while i haven't it's
really bad acting oh it's a really bad
act like it's really bad it's bad i
haven't seen it in a while i want to see
it okay is that weird when you go back
and look at some of that stuff and you
can know like i know i've seen stuff
from like earlier that i've done i'm
like ah that wasn't good yeah oh
absolutely i know that i'm in my head i
watched some of the things that i do
like in the past
that's that green
crack isn't that funny yeah yeah i
didn't get enough sleep the night before
right
yeah
anyway so they let me work there and i
get clueless and it's going to take me
to la
but i still want to keep the job because
it's just the movie oh yeah and my mom
says well i'll fill in for you that's
right and i was like you'll fill in and
she was like yeah i'll fill in for you i
was like all right bet fill in when i
get back i want my job
and i went and did clueless and i was in
la for a few months doing the movie and
i came back and they were like
good news and bad news right good news
is your mom your mom
your mom's going to work here now bad
news is you're never going to work here
again but wait a minute when you when
you get clueless that wasn't that
because amy heckerling who directed that
had already done just fast times and
look who's talking for big movies yeah
but i didn't think that clueless was
gonna be a big oh really no i had no
idea look it felt like fresh off the
boat i had no idea who scott rudin was i
had no idea
yeah i had no idea you know what i mean
like google wasn't around then so you
couldn't be like who is the leader who's
the you know what i mean yeah you know
he's one of the only producers to have
an egot
what's that
uh emmy a a grammy an oscar and a tony
and me a grammy and oscar oh really
well that's
that's the acronym
there's only a few people in the world
that have that oh wow yeah yeah yeah i
don't wow i don't have any of those
letters neither do i neither do i whoopi
goldberg's one like yeah there's very
few people that have it and emmy a tony
an oscar and a
i
grammy
yeah
if steve martin has one oh i don't know
i'm sure he has a grammy
and he doesn't have it sounds like a
neil patrick harris thing to have a knee
got
i'm sure he has an emmy and a tony but i
don't think he has an oscar
yeah
well maybe emergency you'll have an an
um i didn't know i didn't know that
about i thought it was a
um i didn't know that about scott rudin
or about
yeah um this is great yeah uh learned
something new every day bud
[Music]
in the early 2000s millions of
households across the world tuned in to
watch contestants battle for the last
rose or to be the final survivor on the
island reality tv was beginning to
dominate the airwaves and every show
needed to be bigger flashier more
scandalous than the last but in the case
of one infamous dating show the real
drama was happening off-screen and it
would shape the future of reality tv the
reality tv series there's something
about miriam seemed like a pretty
standard dating competition six young
men vibed for the affection of miriam
rivera a beautiful model from mexico but
when miriam revealed that she was a
trans woman during the show's finale the
on-screen drama sparked an international
uproar about gender sexuality and
whether reality television had finally
gone too far follow harsh reality the
story of miriam rivera on apple podcast
amazon music or you can listen early and
add free by joining wondering plus in
apple podcasts or the wondery app
[Music]
hello hello again
we'll meet again i remember thinking
this is going to be
the
worst movie ever why why why because it
was like people talk yeah we were
talking weird and it was like this
doesn't sound like anything for my
neighborhood
you know what i mean yeah i mean you
grew up in harlem well right down the
block actually i grew up literally one
block from where we are right now doing
this no [ __ ] i was born in harlem now so
we're my brothers theater was in harlem
wow like jerry o'connell jerry grew up
on 8th avenue did he yeah i've known
jerry since high school from
professional yeah from the pcs yes
the man he he has a show called the
gerio show oh don't i know it he used to
do that [ __ ] in algebra for everyone oh
really so he was very like outgoing then
and very outgoing what's your name jerry
jerry has taught me a very valuable
lesson in um when people come up to you
people are i think we get a version of
like how do i know you or like they kind
of know that we're actors but we're not
necessarily like a famous actor but
they're like i know that i know you yeah
or i used to kind of like oh i don't
know you know sort of shy away from it i
wouldn't jerry leans into it oh hardcore
my name's jerry o'connell you probably
saw me on maybe jerry mcguire or standby
this is justin he was in dodgeball you
know and it's just right
the way he explained it was like going
into a way when you're surfing you go
into the wave you know uh you just put
your board down and go right into it
it's just easier to deal with and it it
kind of like makes sense you know yeah
my ego gets in the way with that [ __ ]
like when people are like so what have i
seen you guys like
i also get a lot of we went to school
together yeah
no yeah we didn't they're like why went
to professional children's school and
they're like no i didn't go there yeah
college i'm like i didn't go to college
you know you got to do the whole
the whole thing like you're playing this
game that you don't want to [ __ ] play
oh that's i know and it's like jerry's
right just go right into it yeah and
here it is this is how you know me yes
yes you're the most identifiable prank
now we can move on right and now you'll
either say
i like you or i i don't care i've never
seen any of that
and we can go about our day it's the
best
uh it's he's right um so both your
parents were actors i didn't know that
no my dad was a musician and he would
play in the bands and all of that stuff
at the theater and my mom
they were both in the plays and stuff
like that but
my mom went to rutgers for acting
and um
thank you my voice sounds that bad huh
no
my dad for a while was a um
they call it a shabbos [ __ ]
in the orthodox jewish religion they
have they can't turn off you know on
shabbos they can't turn off like if you
operate electricity instead they have
what they call a shabbos [ __ ]
a non-jewish person who is basically
hired to to operate electricity so but
they can't say
i want you to turn on this light they
can't like be direct about it so instead
they have to like kind of dance around
it they have to be like um ah you know
it's a little dark in here it would be
nice if uh
if it were a little lighter so then my
dad had to pick up on those queues and
be like oh i think they want the good
luck
oh wonderful
the lights appear by a miracle of god um
so i don't know why that just reminded
me of uh i guess me being like oh i
could go ahead and get you some water
and i poured you something
um sorry so your dad played so he played
he played the piano and my mom acted a
little bit but she found her passion in
directing and then from directing she
became an agent directing theater
theater yeah plays and were you in any
of these plays so i was in a play she
didn't directed art so i didn't go to
school until third grade um uh we were i
guess it was kind of homeschooling whoa
yeah you know that and uh
and because of that i was always at my
parents theater with a bunch of other
kids who didn't go to school until third
grade weird yeah yeah yeah do you
remember your mom teaching you stuff at
home i don't remember i remember going
to third grade and being like what the
[ __ ] is this
yeah like being so far behind and then
not really liking school with that we
did plays and went that's how i
discovered i wanted to be an actor we
went from you know from new york to
seattle washington on this hippie type
bus called the gray rabbit not greyhound
the gray rabbit and uh did plays for
i'm not going to call it a cult but they
were called the love family and it was a
little close right and but they were
awesome people and the leader of the
love family was this dude named love
and
i remember us going across the united
states on a bus took about five days to
get to seattle washington
and doing a play on their compound
what wait so you were on their bus the
love bus i don't think it was the love
bus this was called the gray rabbit i
don't know right and we went all the way
across
country and then but we stopped in other
places and how cool how fun first sang
on the street and all that stuff and no
parents just
these two teachers oh weird yeah yeah
yeah
and uh i loved it yeah and other kids
were like this sucks and i was like this
is the best day ever everything was
great were you
more outgoing than the kids like your
kids now rocco and wilder are
very outgoing like were you that type of
kid yeah absolutely if you if i could
show you a magic trick even if i didn't
have a magic trick if you like show me a
magic trick i'd be like okay absolutely
let's figure this out we'll take this
pencil
well you're going to love this well i'm
going to make this water right all of
that stuff
dude my pants are totally dry now right
saturate them
completely yeah wow yeah uh and so
uh i remember
much later on being like
that could have been the most dangerous
experience
for us ever like sometimes we didn't
have money for food so we sang on the
streets oh you were like buskers yeah
like holy crap crazy stuff
and uh
so your parents were stayed in new york
and yes two teachers went with you and a
bunch of kids it was like it was like 12
of us or something like that oh it was
me my brother
uh
then like
my best friend and his bro
his sister my other best friend and his
brother and my cousin and his brother
and then a couple of a few other people
and did any of these people end up
becoming actors i was the only one who
became an actor
and they were like forget this
singing for food sucks and then you had
to go back across the country and then
had to go back at the end of it across
the country yeah holy [ __ ] so when you
got to seattle what did you perform on
this compound so it was this play called
when the lion roars and it was about uh
the sun coming to earth to hear a lion
roar
wow yeah my parents were hippies yeah
they were straight up hippies dude and
uh
i remember us your mom has hippie energy
she's like mother earth yeah sort of
like coming with the dreads and yeah
absolutely
absolutely you see my mom and you're
like oh yeah but it's interesting that
you came from her i mean you have an
element of that i like uh well yeah i
look like i smoked a lot of weed at one
point in my life too absolutely yeah
does your mom smoke
i don't know if she does i've smoked
weed with her before
and she
was
she was weird about it she was like dude
we're watching tv i was like yeah mom
we're watching tv she's like no but i'm
like really watching tv right now and
it's like looney tunes no it was friends
or some [ __ ] like that she was like this
is friends and i was like yeah and she's
like i mean no but this is like really
friendly but they're so symbiotic right
i was like mom jesus don't do this it's
really cool it's like i'll never smoke
weed with you oh that's a dream of mine
have you you've never moved your mind no
i would like to so at what point did
your childhood start to become a little
bit more traditional was that third
grade third grade yeah pretty much third
grade wow but
i didn't know
half of the things that i was supposed
to know when i got into third grade you
mean just academic things or like social
facts socially i was fine i was just
yeah
yeah that was the easy part
the
you know authority all of a sudden it
was like what oh yeah
you're gonna do you're gonna tell me i
have to go to the principal right get
out of here yeah i'm just talking in
class
i'm interrupting you raise my wife what
raise my money put my hand in the air
before
crazy stuff i bet so did you ever have a
good relationship with school or was it
always like i want to get out of here
my senior year
well high school
you know
i learned a lot of tricks uh in
high school i remember my freshman year
i was always popular at school and i
remember my freshman year
in high school i wasn't popular at all
like nobody paid attention to freshman
year freshman year and i was like i
gotta fix this
because i can't go to school with all
these [ __ ] huge like you know big
time actors
yeah and big time musicians and not make
my mark i gotta figure out a way to make
money like who are what people besides
jerry o'connell so it was jerry
pretty much everybody from the cosby
show malcolm jamal warner and tempest
blood so
uh sarah michelle gellar
uh
there were quite a few people known
people that were working at the time
yeah as kids
and macaulay caulkin like
after home alone you know wow yeah oh
that's right he was a lot younger than
me but still it was like yeah you know i
got bullied the first year by this one
dude like and i had to call my cousins
to come down and confront this guy
because this dude was bigger than me
and they came from laguardia to kick
this kid's ass and stuff like that how
do actors bully other actors like well i
mean if you're big it's easier
you're bigger that's just how it goes
you know what i mean
i remember being like all right you know
what i'm going to do next year i'm going
to get on the yearbook committee uh
smart and i'll put my face on every page
of the yearbook
that's true so junior year was the best
year ever that's really smart and i've
everybody knew who i was because i was
on everybody's youtube like were your
own publicist it was like pretty much
yeah it was like propaganda
it was definitely it was definitely yes
you will like me yeah yeah if you don't
like me this page just turn another one
right all right i'll be there again
right dude were you bit were you had you
groaned by freshman year were you no i
broke my leg freshman year and then
after the cast came off i had shot up
like six inches oh wow the doctor when i
was a kid i remember crying to my mom
because they were like
the doctor said he's only gonna be like
five
seven weird and then i broke my leg
how'd you break it making fun of a kid
[ __ ] [ __ ] i was such a dick
so yeah and he he it was a karma break
it was a karma break and then this kid
carried me up to my house oh yeah
what a lesson what a lesson how would
you make fun of him he did some move on
the basketball court
and i mimicked him and broke my leg
there's nothing more embarrassing than
that and then he carried me
well at the time i remember being like
dude
i'm so
sorry he's like i know you yeah you've
already been paid back i don't know
he's still the buddy oh that's cool yeah
yeah yeah wait so you so you become
really popular and you're going to prom
every year right and
and and so then did things change by
draft it must have changed trust
drastically junior year
was phenomenal
i was you know i couldn't believe it you
struck me as somebody when i first saw
clueless you struck me as somebody who
was
just on another level of confidence like
by the time you had done clueless was
that was that what that audition was was
that kind of how pretty much but there
were a lot of kids from my school at
that audition i bet and terence howard
was at that audition and you want to
talk about swag i grew up with terence
i've known terry i've known terence
since he was terry
i've known him since he was like 12
years old terry howie terry howard yeah
and i took him to his first audition
with me and he got like i was
auditioning i was like why don't you
crash with me big mistake he got the
[ __ ] car oh really
he got the part uh-huh and i was like
you gotta be kidding me it's it's not
hard enough out here for a pimp dude
right right exactly anyway uh all these
people were auditioning for it and i
remember being like okay i gotta figure
something out because i keep getting
called back for it but i'm not
necessarily giving the best auditions
so all the my friends from my
neighborhood
and lauren hill believe it or not
uh for the final call back before we go
to uh los angeles for it we all get
together in a staircase in my building
and i was supposed to be reading with
lauren hill and she's fuji lie at this
time she's like big time
and uh we get together in the staircase
of my building
and we run lines
and everybody from my neighborhood was
like all right that's cool but kids
would be like i have this idea for your
character or i have this idea for you
trying to help me out to get the role
wow
and i took everything that everybody
took gave me for the audition
and
used it on that audition so cool and i
remember them laughing at jokes that my
buddy gave me and all of this stuff did
any of that make it to the movie none of
it made it to the movie
but it helped me with the audition i
know what i mean and it helped me be
loose and feel free and feel comfortable
like that i've got all of these choices
i can make if i want to use it i can use
it if i don't want to use it i don't
have to use it and you knew it came from
an authentic place and it came from
right it came from something that i knew
and not like the the lines in the movie
were like baldwin and all of these you
know crazy i was like i don't know
half of this you know the audition was
uh the scene where i'm like excuse me
miss dion but street slang is an
increasingly valid form of expression
most of the feminine pronouns do have
mocking but not necessarily misogynistic
undertones oh my god
what a mouthful i say that in the
audition and to start the scene i asked
her for five dollars
my buddy was like you tell her at the
end of that keep your five dollars
oh and i said that and i remember amy
heckling and twink kaplan laughing their
asses off like
oh and i was like oh [ __ ] this this is
the feedback i've been waiting for yeah
and nothing could stop me after that
after that i was like i'm gonna get this
part how many times did you go in
a few so it was originally with sony
before it got to paramount oh yeah you
told me this and so it was like it was
and me being stupid i thought it was
called no worries i
and it was supposed to be no worries
one the clueless years oh but it was in
roman like a freaking [ __ ] dude
no what are you seeing no worries so i'm
going around i'm auditioning for this
thing called no worries i
they keep bringing me back
dummy must be a science fiction movie no
it's about kids in high school they
don't talk
right it is it is weird the dialogue i i
remember hearing it and thinking i had
never heard anything like that before um
the way those characters talked were
unlike anything yeah we grew up in
different worlds but like that was
unlike anything i knew yeah uh so it it
for you to make even that line that you
just said like that is a [ __ ]
mouthful and like
not necessarily how most people talk
no one talks that way
no person yeah but to make that stuff
real as well that's all amy heckling
she's yeah a genius dude yeah how would
she ensure that it was all that stuff
was grounded and real and we were kids
and so it came from honesty you know
what i mean like even though we were
learning these big lines we were all
literally kids all really hungry so
you know for to be grounded she was just
like just
do what you just do it's all right don't
worry about it you know what i mean it's
honest just be honest with it and
there's that natural sense of like play
yeah
you and brecken and everybody
even paul you know paul had
never done anything before
really you know what i mean all right
yeah and he was
he was surrounded he was the only one in
the whole cast that could drink at the
time you know what i mean
it was crazy i remember my first time
ever getting a drink legally was with
breckenmeier paul rudd and alicia
silverstone oh my god weird yeah
did you think that that this would be
what it became i mean any idea adam
schroeder was the one that told me this
is going to be a hit movie
who's adam schroeder i think he's one of
the producers oh okay
and i was like it is
look man everybody's gonna love this
it's gonna be great we can tell already
now and i was like okay
before you've had experience doing
movies where like every person every
producer says that right so he says and
i'm i believe it yeah yeah and also he
was the first person to ever humble me
because i'm walking around thinking i'm
hot [ __ ] on this set you know pretty
much playing this character and i'm like
who's the best actor at 20 right now
that you know
he's like huh i was like who's the best
actor fishing and fishing for him to be
like yeah well donald faison yeah be
honest with you
and he goes
oh
hmm
leonardo dicaprio
that's a good answer and i was like oh
that's still true
yeah still to this day to this day he
still likes it right you know what i
mean i don't feel like oh okay with
second paper right and then it was like
54th favorite right
he never said my name
but yeah i remember being so arrogant
and and i guess it had to be for there
was no yeah it had to be for that role
pretty natural yeah i mean you do kind
of like have humility right all of it
all of the things that i did in that
movie were literally me trying to
take the things that i saw growing up in
fast times in the breakfast club and you
know all of these white characters i was
trying to do my best version of the
black guy
at that i wanted to be ice cube but i
also wanted it to be where
all the girls would be like he's jake
ryan or he's you know what i mean it's
interesting yeah that was important or
he's jud nelson from the breakfast club
you know what i mean he's benderman i i
wanted i wanted that feel from that
character because you had never seen
that archetype that high school
architect representative ever yeah ever
and i didn't want to come across as a po
even though he's a huge poser yeah i
didn't want to come across as this huge
poser i wanted if anything he's posing
to be ice cube he's like i'm the black
kid at the white school but i really
want to be ice cube you know that's
interesting but he's not because of his
socioeconomic reality right exactly oh
that's interesting
but when you said you talked in much
different way i mean like you
what you knew about socializing and
language was much different yeah well
keeping it real came from me oh that was
actually something that i brought to the
table that's the first time i think i'd
ever heard anyone say that
i heard it in my neighborhood yeah i'm
keeping it real yeah and i was like you
know what i'm keeping it real that's
gonna be in this movie and i waited and
i waited and then that [ __ ] happened and
i was like oh this is perfect because
i'm keeping it cause i'm keeping it real
you repeat it a couple cause i'm keeping
it real yeah and i got it in there
and i couldn't believe it uh that's cool
god isn't that amazing to be able to
influence i mean that brought
your what you knew your culture to
somebody like me right to right somebody
like me right hey guys
oh and i started saying all the time
it's lit af
it's sort of like yes queen yeah
that's a real question
when we were doing the play i don't know
how that started but we started saying
yes queen yes to everybody to add to
everybody and then it just became our
the way we affirmed things oh uh do you
want to go to this restaurant yeah
that's queen
hey uh so you sure you can do my podcast
yeah that's clean
life could be a dream
how long after that is scrubs how does
scrubs so scrubs so
after clueless clueless ran three years
one year on uh
abc and then two years on the upn
network uh-huh
and then after clueless while doing that
i did a couple of movies like uh
this movie tripping with my buddy dion
richmond
trip no tripping oh sorry
yeah i saw you posted that on instagram
uh
tripping
we call it tripping no
you all say tripping too don't even try
it
don't don't go tripping don't start
tripping on us
became like a massive hit again yeah so
now you that's gotta make like does that
make life easier does that just like
make life more fun you get to go to a
regular job that you like it's great
yeah it's i met zach braff during it you
know i everything's still a good friend
still a great friend yeah and people
seem to be very into your uh are bromine
romance yeah more than they are into me
and
individually
it's ridiculous yeah i post a picture of
me and zach and it's like a hundred
thousand people like this yeah well
and also i've heard people call you turk
i mean like
brown bear all of that [ __ ] what's brown
bear that's the name that zach gave me
on the show oh oh okay chocolate bear
brown because my skin's brown
as big as a [ __ ] [ __ ] that is true
brown bear's a good nickname for you
but you're not ferocious but you have
you're cuddling but i'm cuddly yeah i'm
so cuddly like a brown bear yeah that's
funny
but you
that show is so beloved too i mean so
people must that must be a component of
like why they like your instagram
absolutely yeah like they love us
together yeah as those two characters
did did you guys hit it off right away
was it yeah yeah it was the minute we
met each other we knew that's the best
there was something special yeah yeah
speaking of that how did you meet casey
your wife casey cobb so to me sounds
like a baseball player she does sound
like a baseball player right chaos
starting pitcher
i guess it's ty cobb and casey casey
yeah right
um zach turned 30.
and he threw a party at 40 deuce oh boy
everybody's up in there you know what i
mean it's a big time scene yeah
and he threw a part he there his 30th
birthday party there and jessica was
there with casey jessica simpson jessica
simpson was there with casey and
i was there with someone else and i
remember going
yeah with zach and i remember going to
the bar
seeing her and not really knowing who
she was but i knew she was there with
jessica and i knew jessica had an
assistant on the show
that everybody was talking about who was
this cute girl from texas i was like
maybe this is her she also as i recall
on the show was kind of the voice of
reason was kind of like chesco when you
can't do that right yeah
that's a very appealing combination
absolutely yeah so i said hey how's it
going and she turned around and she was
like hey
as a joke no like like it's on what's up
uh-huh and i was like oh [ __ ] and i
looked over my shoulder to see if she
was saying somebody else no if if the
girl that i was there i saw this [ __ ]
and she didn't i was like hey
and then casey goes
oh no i thought you i i know who you are
now you're okay i i thought i knew you i
don't know you oh
it was a mistaken yeah i i my bad sorry
about that
don't tell your man
i can't take like a hey
i i hate you yeah i gave you the hay we
did the hair i'm not taking mine back
right my hair is real and i was like all
right well can we at least take a
picture together she was like yeah sure
why not so we take a picture
and
i have a bunch of pictures from that
night on
this camera and i'm going through the
pictures with my then at the time
girlfriend
and we're going through all of them and
i pass over the picture
and i go wait a second i go back and i'm
trying to be clever about it
right
trying to be clever about it
and i'm like who is this girl
and she goes oh that's casey cobb and i
was like case in my my mind casey cobb
[Music]
me and this girl break up uh-huh it's
shocking yeah
you saw it coming
and now my mission is when i see casey
i'm going to
spit game i don't care what she says i'm
going to give my i'm going to shoot my
shot and let's see what happens i would
i wish i could have been there for that
oh gosh it didn't go well oh okay
so we're at rose now we're at teddy's
okay at the roosevelt hotel me and zach
at teddy's yeah and i'm like oh and
she's dancing with tay diggs right
and i'm like oh [ __ ] she's dancing with
a black dude she's getting a group back
no right yeah she danced with a black
dude i'm gonna dance with her so it's
not one of those white girls in
hollywood that does never date to black
dude yeah yeah that's all i see oh i got
a shot at this but it's also like jesus
tate dude it's hey
like it's you're stepping up to the
right it's black tom cruise yeah you
know what i mean yeah it's it's the most
handsome dude on the planet yeah you
know what i mean with a lot at this time
a lot of heat behind his head yeah you
know what i mean even the bro is like
most homophobic guys would be like yeah
yeah holy tea digs
and i was like well i'm gonna chew my
shot anyway uh-huh wow and so i go up
and i start dancing and she goes uh-uh
and i was like what
out loud yeah he goes she goes he's
married he's safe
you're not
and i was like what
[Music]
why are you dancing with a married man
dude what the what the hell is wrong
with you
and she's like
she kind of knew if i'm gonna if i
wanted to dance with her i'd try and
push up hard uh-huh and she was like i
just want to dance
all night with state digs like oh [ __ ]
i don't know i don't know what tay's
mindset was
i don't know what his mindset was at
that time in his in his life anyway so
she goes back and i'm like i'm gonna ask
him when he's on
i was like so what's up with you and her
and to him he was like oh nothing dude i
was like oh oh oh oh okay good good good
um
cool and i go over to zack and i was
like all right look
from what i gather she doesn't have a
boyfriend she just works for jessica
simpson i need you to go over there
because you know jessica
uh from your birthday party
and freaking tell her that i kind of
like her
he's like what
he's like yes
total high school [ __ ]
and he's like all right fine whatever
dude he's like wait do you want me to
say you like like her yeah
no just tell her i like her yeah i
so he goes over there and he's like uh
so
you see my friend over there he
totally likes you and he would love to
get your number she's like hey diggs no
no and uh she looks over at me and then
she looks to him
and he goes
and walks back
and i was like what what the [ __ ] what
happened what'd she say he was like so i
told her you liked her and you wanted to
get her number and she was like doesn't
he have like nine kids
[Laughter]
no only four only four only four
no wait i hate to interrupt this this is
good but when
you see him this is always an
embarrassing moment when you see him
talking to her right
are you pretending not to look at that
of course of course but over my you know
i'm doing a little side eye thing where
i'm trying to check up from the side
yeah just trying to look like right like
i'm but i'm chilling and i'm trying to
you know be chill again but you don't
really care but like right like just go
to make it happen drinking a beer but
i'm really like you know
and he comes back and he says that and i
was like oh
it's never going to happen and he was
like i don't know dude man i don't i you
know maybe this isn't not enough this is
right but this isn't the one that's
gonna
and then i ran into her again
and this time i ran into her
and i'm with terence howard he's now
been nominated for
uh the academy award it's not out yet
the the academy award hasn't happened
yet but he's nominated we're at an oscar
party at teddy's once again
and i'd done this movie
and
uh
prince
is
uh best friends with the director of the
movie
and he's like prince is not geeking out
but as much as prince could geek out
yeah he's [ __ ] you know what i mean
like donald i'm really excited to see
this movie i felt that and i was like
holy [ __ ]
so now it's funny the idea of prince
geeking out but that's that's
i'm very excited to see this movie
you're like i'm down and i was alright
and i'm there with terrence and terence
is nominated so terence is like yo let's
go meet prince so we're sitting down
with prince but prince is hanging out
with jessica and casey oh wow and so we
sit down with him
and casey's like comes over and it's
like you guys gotta move
uh this is our
we're at this section i was like i'm not
going anywhere get the [ __ ] out of here
you're bugging if you think i'm leaving
right now this is gonna be the only time
i get to ever talk to prince and
bugging's worse than tripping right
bugging is definitely worse than trouble
just like tripping you're like oh my god
your mind is bugging is like dude this
could turn into a fight okay get the
[ __ ] out of here there's no way you're
bugging if you think i'm leaving it but
you must have done it in like a flirty
fun way absolutely not oh absolutely not
i was like get oh get out of here yeah
hell no i'm not going anywhere now like
well prince can't sit down if you'd sit
there i was like chris could sit right
here
you can't sit down he doesn't need that
much he's a pretty long guy right here
so me and now so terry and i terence and
i now have him flanked uh-huh and
jessica's sitting over here like uh
across from us and casey has to stand
and i remember just talking to prince
and then leaving again so now this time
she knows prince likes me
and so there and your face in your face
you got to mean something right not that
it's going to make her like me but there
it could have it couldn't hurt right
look you don't you i know you're here
with him and you guys will probably hang
out when i'm gone and all of that stuff
yeah but
there's no way that you can deny the
fact that the coolest [ __ ] on
the planet yeah likes me yeah you saw me
think about that
you
right we should tell everyone at this
point that you do
have four kids right now no no no at
that point
and but how long had you been divorced
at that point
for at least two years okay two to three
years okay so you're
i'm single and single and single and
this is like the one time in my whole
life that i've ever been really single
yeah right
so uh
i see her again
out she's like hey how's it going i'm
like hey how's it going
and now all of a sudden it's not like
she's trying to spit game at me but
she's used to me always seeing her and
trying to be near her
and so she tells stories of how she
would be like we're going out tonight we
might see donald faison
he's going to hit on me
whatever oh god right and so one night
you must have sensed that energy from
her absolutely yeah
so
it started happening a lot where we
would run into each other and i'd be
like hey how's it going and she's like
hey i'd be like let me get your number
and she'd be like not tonight and i'd be
like what
hold on why not why what the whatever
she was like she was like not tonight
maybe some other time next time i see
you i'll give it to you and i was like
all right so
she definitely there's something
definitely there because she's saying
not tonight she's she's saying not
tonight she and she's not saying no did
she ever explain why
she said that or not because she was she
was playing the end game is what she
says she's playing a slow
game so was she afraid that you were
just like a player that you were like
she was like she said she knew i had
just gotten out of relationship and she
didn't want me to be another like notch
on the bill right yeah yeah she did she
right i i mean i you are an interesting
mix of like you're
tremendously respectful i can't imagine
you ever disrespecting a woman or being
you are a gentleman yes but you are also
i can see women thinking you're like
flirtatious or whatever absolutely yeah
absolutely
so
one night i'm out and this is a really
long story i'm sorry no this is good one
night i'm out with my cousin and uh
scarlett johansson is at this party that
we're at and i'm like oh my god
scarlett johansson
yo
let me go talk to her so i go talk to
her and the thing that we have in common
is we both went to pcs sure
with jerry with jerry yeah she was a
little bit younger than us yeah but
i'm just trying to talk to her
i'm not really trying to get with her
but i'm trying to talk to her like yo
but you wouldn't be disappointed if she
was like
let's exchange numbers and talk
i would have been like this is the best
we did exchange numbers but it wasn't to
be boyfriend and girlfriend it was to
just be like cordial like oh okay we
know i know who you are you know why
anyway and i'm like holy [ __ ] and we're
talking and we're talking
and we're talking about school
but we're having conversation so
everybody around us is like what the
hell are they talking about
and i get a tap on my shoulder and i
turn around and it's casey and so now
i'm like
i don't need to talk to scarlett anymore
she made her way all the way over here
to talk to me let me turn it's like a
wilmer valderrama party so it's loaded
with people she made the effort to talk
to me let me turn around and talk to her
and i'm like hey how's it going she goes
i'm here with someone but i saw you
across the room i just wanted to say hi
and then turns around and walks away
interesting and i was like what what
i turn around scarlet's gone
so now
this this this person that i'm having
this conversation with is gone and and
casey is there with some other dude i
didn't see her for a long time
and now hyde is poppin
and i'm at hyde with zach his girlfriend
at the time seems like a pattern here
right
and casey walks in
i don't pay her any attention because i
know where it's gonna lead
and she comes up she goes hey
and i go hey how's it going and i turn
back around and i start talking with
zach and his
girlfriend at the time and our buddy and
she goes well i was going to give you my
number but i guess now i won't
immediately jumped up and was like you
did what let's do it let's do it and she
does it
and
i'm like let's go out she's like when i
was like this weekend she was like what
do you want to do i said i'm taking you
to see superman the returns it's
superman returns
she's like all right fine whatever
and the movie comes out and we don't go
see that but we wind up going and
hanging out at uh remember damiano's the
pizza restaurant right next to the dime
so we ate french fries on our first date
and i told her my whole life story wow
and i told her how many kids i had and
how i got divorced and what i did to get
divorced and how what i did to not have
an ex-girlfriend anymore i told her
everybody just very honest just as
honest as i possibly could be
and from that moment on we were always
together that's amazing yeah yeah yeah
now do you have did you feel like you've
learned as a father how do you feel
because you have two sets of like you
have four kids right they're older and
the youngest one now is
18 almost 20 oh my god the out of the
four out of those four the youngest is
18 now he'll be 18 in october
were there things that you're doing i
mean i don't know how to ask this
without it sounding like
like you didn't do a good job the first
time around but i didn't i do i did a
horrible job the first time i was i was
a good dad i just wasn't a good husband
i mean uh
and it took
you know i'd shoot i've i did a lot of
really bad things that i look back and
i'm like damn you know what i wish i
would have just been a little bit more
present in my kid's life
yeah uh during the divorce and after the
divorce now kobe lives with me oh yeah
kyle lives with mikaya is going to cal
state northridge you know what i mean
awesome and we have a great relationship
but at the time i was just a selfish
[ __ ] well you were also it was at the
height your career yeah scrubs was on
yeah you know there was so there were so
many things being thrown at me i mean
i'm not giving you like an app i know
there's no hanging out but it's like i
know what those hours are it's not
you're not working in a coal mine but
it's um but you're never home yeah when
you and you know it was it was horrible
it was it was not good to be married at
that time because of how young i was one
but also how immature i was for you know
what i mean i did not take my marriage
seriously well how old were you when you
got married you were you i was 20 it was
right after
uh
like when i did remember the titans i
turned 25 so it was right around my mind
when scrub the first season of scrubs
after the pilot and scrubs got picked up
i had gotten married by the season three
i was divorced you're on a show now that
premiered uh it's premiering this week
yes uh wink wink we're recording earlier
i'm so bad at that i can't lie to my
friend don't worry about uh
emergence on abc it looks
so cool i'm not saying this you're my
friend i've been watching those they're
since i've been watching the bachelor
i've been seeing a lot of emergencies a
lot of the trailers yeah is it
do you think it's as i know you have to
say it is as good as it um
but
is it as good as it looks because i'll
be able to tell the difference uh yeah
it is i've i haven't been this excited
for a show since
scrubs no kids so it looks cool yeah
this is one way you know you always say
oh it's such a good show it's such a
good show and you don't really mean it
this
like i am very happy to be a part of
this show like i feel like i don't know
man i feel you know you you know when
you have the feeling just if people
watch it i promise you you'll enjoy it
right it's not one of those shits where
you'll be like that was [ __ ] it's one of
those
it's one of tho you know what i mean
it's gonna look so good on the poster
right it's not one of those shits where
you're like this is [ __ ] right what is
your most commonly used emoji
uh the eggplant
such a good answer one of the reasons i
love it is why we're friends
um if you could be a professional
athlete what sport would you play
basketball okay um
nick's right next fan for life yeah yeah
this season might be uh the worst season
ever it might be true yeah yeah uh if
you'd have one snack food for the rest
of your life reese's peanut butter cup
oh that's right
i remember you were smoking
the good old dude
by the way how do you what do you i have
this conversation with my brother a lot
what do you call weed what's a not every
word i can think of whenever i talk
about it is like sounds like wow so it's
weed
buddha or
god's green lettuce or if you were to
say oh i smoked
you just asked ganja ganja ganja it's
cool herb herb
favorite movie of all time empire
strikes back oh yeah
you saw in the movie theater
like
a million times yeah you're a huge star
wars fan um
has that form
formed any of your opinions about
religion or the afterlife you didn't
grow up with religion
i grew up with spirituality not
necessarily religion but i definitely
believe that there's got to be some
power powering this whole thing and i
don't mean just us as humans i mean this
whole universe there's something you
know what i mean if you want to get
microscopic there's universes inside of
this cup of water you know what i mean
in our hands and our bodies there's just
a bunch of electrons and protons and
neutrons and all of that stuff is
spinning and orbiting each other who's
to say that this isn't
being powered by something like that
we're not just a speck on some we are
definitely a speck
on a little tiny rock in this
bass so to subscribe to some sort of
like judeo-christian set of beliefs
would be like what what arrogance that
we are the only that were the chosen you
know i
i cannot believe that yeah i do believe
that i do believe that it's fine to have
your beliefs and and to believe in what
you believe in but i
i don't necessarily you know
i don't necessarily think that it's just
uh
it's everybody's one religion is correct
i think there has to be truth in all of
it obviously because somebody wrote
about it and so somebody experienced
something in there yeah did casey grow
up with that did you did you have to
determine like how we're going to raise
rock online grew up catholic yeah and if
franco believes in god and finds god
then good for him
go for it you know what i mean go all
the way you know
but i'm just not going to push my i
don't know my beliefs on
him except for star wars you're going to
be well yeah he's already a star wars
fan yeah and he can look that's a lot of
religion right there totally you know
what i mean there's a whole mythology
yeah uh okay almost done uh if you had
to live somewhere else where would it be
other than california yeah new york um
if you could have dinner with three
people dead or alive whom you've never
met
okay uh i'd love to meet martin luther
king obviously yeah uh malcolm x
obviously
and harrison ford
oh man
that'd be a great dinner it would be a
weird weird it would be weird yeah
person would be like what am i doing
here
your favorite muppet
oh gosh ah
[ __ ] you uh oh
man
grove oh it just goes on it goes on
grover's great ah you know who i
realized i haven't thought about enough
lately is remember beauregard yeah i
loved him the janitor yes yeah yeah yeah
he was so funny and he had those little
fun hat and everything the hat but those
little wispy hairs would stick out right
dude uh
uh so
it's grover and it's oh gosh uh if you
could have one superpower what would it
be
uh
to read minds uh yeah if you'd be
reincarnated as a non-human animal uh
what would you be i guess a wolf oh yeah
yeah a wolf
i like the way you said that yeah that'd
be the that's yeah yeah yeah because you
could be a loner or you could run with a
pack
yeah do you and you kind of mix you do
both yeah i
well every you have a pack now look of
my kids yeah that's about it but let's
keep it honest when you move to
california yeah you start off trying to
find the group that you fit in and then
you realize you know what i like being
with me
way more than
that's true all than running with this
pack of that's true people so our packs
used to cross cross
paths absolutely and and i miss a lot of
those i mean i miss those days and those
guys but it's true at a certain point
and people get families and just right
at a certain point you realize it
becomes a little yeah it's better just
me yeah it's gotta be tested yeah uh
would you camping or glamping
oh camping uh dogs or cats dogs [ __ ] a
cat
not literally beetle stones
beetles
for sure right yeah yeah yeah i know i
like the stones too but i totally i feel
the same um you're the best man no
you're the best i i kiss you i miss you
uh emergency is tuesday nights 10
o'clock 10 o'clock
on abc you're the best thanks i never
not end these it's all good okay goodbye
all right uh
maybe a line from clueless uh no let's
keep it 100 let's keep it real let's
keep it real all right
[Music]
[Laughter]
we've done it so many times now that
we've uh confused ourselves i don't
think it's that just happening i think
it's well that happened yeah you started
adding adjust and then chastise me for
not getting it right uh so let's agree
on it well that happened that happened
okay okay with a well or so so i don't
know whatever it happened it happened uh
he is incredibly confident he's that was
my biggest takeaway from it he's an
incredibly confident human being yeah
i've always but not obnoxiously that's
the difference so i i i know maybe
that's why i hesitate to describe him
that way because it's usually
to say somebody is confident usually
suggests that their cockiness yeah yeah
it's very often difficult to separate
confidence from cockiness but he does
not seem cocky at all but extremely
confident and a lot of the stories he
told were like then i walked up to this
girl and that girl and this girl and
this guy
and there was every time he said that i
was like i don't think i've ever done
that once in my life just walked up to
someone and been like hey my name's
christian no i know i'm gonna buy you a
drink i've never done that no i know so
people who do do that are
i admire them so much
me too and those that do it in a way
that isn't like creepy and aggressive
and weird but just that act of walking
walking to somebody's stranger i know
and and
introducing yourself i i wouldn't know
how to do that yeah as donald would say
like spit in game you know i don't know
if you would say that spitting games
spitting games
i shouldn't put that in his mouth um i
don't know if he would say that but he
is capable and it reminds me actually of
that first my introduction to donald
which was many of yours was that shot in
clueless when he just walks up and she's
like stacy dash says oh there's my
boyfriend um and
and he just comes right in and it's like
he exudes this confidence i mean he's
leaning to it's more cockiness in
clueless he's playing that character
who's what's up girl he's just very like
yeah he talked about that i thought that
was interesting that he said he he was
playing a poser really like that that
character was a bit of a poser but he
didn't want to play it like a poster
like he didn't want to be a poser you
know yeah uh so he tried to make it as
authentic as possible because i'm
keeping it real and that's a big part of
that movie i mean he talks about it i
don't know why that line really struck
me because i think it was the first time
i ever heard that that's great well i
think i think he introduced that into
the internet yeah the lexicon uh
it was fun to hear you guys reminisce
i've never i'd i've still never met him
but um that's weird to me but i still
enjoyed hearing you guys talk about
stuff that i wasn't a part of oh that's
good it was fun to listen to he's fun
he's just fun to go out with because
like you said he is not at all shy about
talking to people and i love that i mean
i love the idea of just being able to
ingratiate yourself in a group of
strangers um
and again he does it in a way that is
like
you know it's never
even when he talks about casey like that
story about
meeting casey it's like there's a
version of that story if you read it
that sounds like it could be kind of
creepy or like dude she doesn't want to
go out with you like
layoff you know um
oh really see i i had a different take
on that oh really that she was uh she
was streaming on for a long time um
and well you're a sexist
that's true yeah everyone knows that
don't listen to me yeah uh yo really
okay well maybe i'm not remembering yeah
i mean i know it was a lot of like why
not go out with him either you will or
you won't um well see it's funny
that i mean there's a long story and and
i i'll reduce it to this
she became interested in him after he
was pursuing her for months on months
and months i think that like a year she
finally became interested in him why
because
one
she saw him hanging out with prince and
that was a cool association two she saw
him talking to scarlett johansson and
then she tapped him on the shoulder
pretty cool and three and this was the
straw that broke the camel's back the
cob's back the cops back he kind of like
blew her off once
you know yeah she was like hey good to
see you and he was like hey what's up
you know you didn't give her the time of
day yeah and then she was like let's
hang out that's true so those are
impressive moments though in a in a
courtship i think a pre-court ship they
are but well also he had a reputation
maybe or she so she thought as being
like god you're such a casey cobb
apologist i am i'm a cupologist
[Laughter]
uh but well because i know casey too and
she's
great i mean like she's i don't know
either of them so i'm very subjective
right now that's true that's true
i think it's fair to say that you if
anything happens to zach braff i hope it
doesn't but i think it's
it's pretty safe to say that you could
stand in for him in their in their
bromance if anything happens yeah i
think you guys would be
you'd be a good zack graf substitute
i'm i'm brafish um oh okay so the
interview started i wasn't there for it
so i just heard the recording
it started uh with you guys talking
about pooping with the door open and
uh
i was so curious well here's how it oh
how that started oh yeah that's right
because they didn't
you know before there's a there's a
storm there's like that electricity in
the air there's like the air smells
different before like a thunderstorm
rolls in and it's like that like
there's something in the air
that's what happens in a room before
donald enters it he comes in with such
gusto and life and like what's up you
know and we hadn't seen each other in a
while and he's just a big bear like he
talks about it on the show he's like a
big
bear and
well not not like not like a big bear in
chelsea oh no no
but he comes in and with just this such
energy that like uh part of it was like
p energy uh he's like i gotta go pee i
gotta go to the bathroom i said oh we
gotta record this let's record it
whatever we were laughing about
recording him potentially pooping
i'm so glad i asked i'm sorry
you did ask well good to know yeah in
context so that's you now you know why
they cut that out he
he was talking about you thinking his
brother is older even though he's
younger yeah and i feel him on that yeah
i often get
who's older between you two and i'm all
i shouldn't be because who gives a [ __ ]
really but
i'm always a little insulted because i
am
three years younger than justin three
and a half three and a quarter my
instinct is always
to think oh i just i'm not aging well if
they think i'm the same age like where
did those three years go
yeah but then i suppose we're both about
40 yeah and at a certain point i know
three years isn't a whole lot you know
it's not like it's not like you're eight
and i'm five and people can't yeah when
would it be genuinely insulting on one
when would it be like the most insulting
four and one
three and zero
you're talking about meeting steve
martin and
you both decided to do the play in part
yeah in large part because you thought
he was gonna be a huge part of it yeah
that's what they imply more than implied
i remember that yeah you're whoever your
agent at the time was was like
was like he's going to be there night
and day it's funny they didn't mention
him they just said the writer will be
there every day we'll be working on it
they're working on it that's funny but
you were talking about how you're
disappointed by that and by meeting him
but think about how much
worse it would have been if you met him
and he was a complete dick i know yeah
no i know and and worst worst case
scenario is if he wasn't was difficult
and
and he's working on the thing the whole
time exactly so you're kind of i know
you're you should be happy that he
wasn't really part of it it's funny when
when the director of that play came to
new york we went to see a steve martin
play called meteor shower which amy
schumer was in and uh it's really fun
play really good play uh and afterwards
we went to the they had like an opening
night partying
and the director my friend barry
edelstein is very good friends with
steve martin and he said do you want to
go but steve was like in a back room and
you know with like uh fancy people
around and he said do you want to i'm
going to go say hi meet him do you want
to do you want to come he said i think
martin short's there with him
and
i really regret this now but i said no i
left i said yeah i just i i felt like
too much pressure to meet those guys in
that environment yeah and also
what are you going to get from meeting
someone like that i know or like mickey
mouse
what really well not me i mean i'm
saying oh you mean
yeah not now well that just took a turn
to meet you too
i love your work
yeah are you still with minnie
as many as me
oh they didn't they're just sisters
their siblings uh i think they're just
friends friends mickey and minnie they
just remain friends chip and dale like
well they're like frog and toad like
burton ernie hold on hold on well you
just threw a lot out there
chip and dale are siblings i think no
what do you mean they have different
color noses who cares
they have similar we have different
features we don't have different color
noses no but that's the one thing that
makes them different that's very
different chip and dale are not brothers
i think you're wrong they're friends
alvin and alvin's uh brothers with the
other chipmunks that's true okay and now
bernie they're friends they're roommates
what's going on there well
i think they're a little more than
friends but
[Music]
what do you think they are
i think they're i think they're hetero
life mates and who are the other ones oh
frog and toad i love you they're just
friends too arnold lobel
uh yeah i guess so there were a lot of
adult friends in children's literature
and pop culture i think chip and dad are
just friends why i just started talking
about mickey and minnie i think mickey
and minnie are kind of oh mickey and
minnie
i don't think so anyway if you write in
if you happen to write in and we'll get
to the letters because if mickey and
minnie were a couple how come they never
had children well you don't have to not
a lot of couples don't necessarily have
kids i know but but in that disney world
you'd think that if they were a couple
they would have produced
little mice well uh kermit and miss
piggy never had like a half
they weren't they weren't sexual with
each other they were they were kermit
and miss piggy of course they were
you've never seen muppets manhattan
they're very
miss piggy's furious at the thought of
him being with other
with being with a frog with his own kind
oh really yeah remember when he meets
like jill and gill
oh yeah so they have sex why don't they
have sex but they're amorous they're
they kiss
i think miss me
kermit kiss
uh he told he taught you what an egot
was oh
i never heard that but i think i've seen
it in print
and it's emmy grammy oscar tony so if
you're an e if you have an egot you have
all four of them god and i wondered he
said it so casually
yeah and i wondered
why they chose that as an acronym but
then i realized it's e-g-o-t it's in
alphabetical order
but it's such an ugly sounding acronym
why not
goat
g-o-t-e because that's a homophone of oh
yeah g-o-a-t goat yeah and it's like
greatest of all time and so that it's a
more appropriate acronym for
yeah egot doesn't sound um
it doesn't sound uh
what's the word i can't think of words
yeah egot doesn't sound um
impressive yeah significant
uh sounds like a problem oh i got an
egot
i got this e god i'm dealing with i
thought it was interesting that he
thought clueless was going to be bad
because because the script because
people were talking in it in such a
different way yeah in such a different
way than what he was used to growing up
in new york and he was like this is
crazy this isn't going to be good yeah
uh i thought it was interesting that he
performed for a cult when he was a kid
uh oh yeah and he just said it so
casually he was like i'm not gonna say
it's a cult but and then you went on to
describe
he was like no it's just in a big open
field and everyone wore robes and their
names were mr and mrs love love pepper
and yeah it's like oh that's a cult it's
like maybe not jonestown but it's yeah
he talked about smoking pot with his mom
and you said oh something i would like
to do with my mom and uh
i disagree
i would not want to do that with our mom
oh yeah it would make my
brain melt probably
it would be very upsetting for me yeah
maybe i didn't think that went through
uh i love that his favorite emoji is the
eggplant and he said it so confidently
so quickly
no hesitation yeah that was the
i know you know those moments when
you're talking to somebody that you
really like and you're like that's why i
like you yeah um yeah yeah but all those
short questions he's again i know i keep
coming back to this but very confident
like very sure of himself very sure of
what he likes when he doesn't like yes
um eggplant and there was no
it was unnecessary to
expand like yeah
he's the best um god damn it i would
totally rip i mean i don't want anything
to happen to zach braff but um and by
the way
nothing has to happen it doesn't have to
be like a dramatic thing for me to have
a bromance with donald i could we could
both be we could have i could be like a
threesome
oh god
you just got a visual
speaking of eggplant emojis
um let's read a letter okay great yeah
this is from temple f right temple f
importance of family it's called
listening to you interact with each
other makes me so grateful for my
brother
in december of 2010 our our mother died
at her mother's funeral
you read it right her grandmother died
on christmas day jesus
and three days later our mother suffered
a pulmonary embolism at the funeral and
died right there oh lord i'm temple
i'm so sorry there was no one and i mean
no one on planet earth who understood
what i was going through other than my
brother in the years since their deaths
my brother and i have become no more
alike than we were before now though
i appreciate that he is there we are now
in a place where honesty reigns and we
can have those conversations about what
we need from each other and we laugh
about the absurdity of losing them both
in that way we call it the worst
lifetime movie never written
we understand that the only way to
handle the weight of the grief is to
share it and to juggle it back and forth
sometimes listening to the two of you
talk always reminds me that he is and
always will be my person
love temple uh temple
uh you have brought me two tears that is
incredibly uh moving and um
yeah i can't imagine going through
something like that at all um but then
if you have no one to share it with to
share that kind of grief through tragedy
you've kind of embraced
the good you know you've embraced uh
your your relationship with your brother
but you still have you know and that's
strengthened your connection and that
it's probably strengthening your
connection to your
grandma and your mom who
you know you you have to remember
together now it probably helps it uh
that memory that collective memory
uh thank you so much for that temple and
thanks to everyone writing in uh if
you'd like to write in
and just tell us uh you know anything
whatever uh life is short at wondery.com
and thanks for listening we really like
hearing from you guys
life could be a dream
life could be a dream
life is short is uh hosted by me justin
long yeah yeah
what else it's produced by
christian long
and megan monaco our senior producer is
michelle
miesh lance
our audio engineer is marcelino via
hondo
and our executive producers are marshall
louis and hernan lopez for wondering
but she was also that was kind of why
she was funny she was delusional
she was a delusional character
yeah so we would laugh at her like she
if miss piggy was around today she would
become successful and she wouldn't be
funny anymore
but wait a minute
yeah that's true that's true
that's true she'd be selfish
like she'd be like snooker she's like
snooky yeah yeah like snooki knows she's
talentless probably
yeah
but what made or does she or does she
think she's
yeah
better what does it mean to value as a
entertainment value she would probably
say i'm funny
i'm funny i'm gonna be right i bet
snooki would think she's funny
yeah because think about it if you're
such a snookie well funny how
i guarantee you she's been called funny
in like
by the way
it's very much like miss piggy millions
of times
oh yeah oh yeah to the point where she
really believes even if she didn't think
she was funny before she became famous
right now she thinks but isn't that
crazy but in miss piggy's time
she that kind of mentality was mocked
was like laughed at
and now and celebrate now like snooki is
like people do probably say she's
so then she doesn't even understand why
at least miss piggy we know it's fake
she's like a fake
she's a she's a puppy she's a puppet
uh so like no one would really ever
act like like the thought of that's why
we can laugh but miss piggy is like oh
she's so full of herself and like
she's just like not that talented the
way she sings and that yeah i don't
think like
in fact kermit's always more
i don't know they did but they like do
performances together but i think it's
just like oh that's cool to watch
because it's a big
frog
you know it's not like they're like
talented
if they were humans even if kermit isn't
caring
like if you were a human it'd be like
that guy's a weird
he's like a marginally talented likes
weirdo yeah but couldn't you say the
same thing about all the other muppets
that they're fun to watch because
exactly yeah no i know they're like i
know weird looking i know i know what
i'm saying that's why
they can be so extreme and like miss
piggy
is such an extreme uh character to la to
laugh at
because it's absurd that someone would
behave that like her well not only
behave that way but someone who's who
has no talent
well she does much miss baby's much more
talented like i mean for a human than
snooki or they can't do any they don't
do anything except like versions of
themselves
snooki's just like kind of i guess she's
good at being
a version of like a shitty hopefully
shittier version than of herself
uh
that's is that a talent maybe
they are acting well you don't really
need to be i guess the lessons you don't
need talent to entertain
because yeah of course not yeah because
look at all those so they're
entertaining someone tripping is
entertaining yeah
especially if they're i mean if they're
not if they're like a sweet like
sweet old like nuns paraplegic
you